remember the time of my life adele's on
cloud nine with boyfriend rich paul
and she's opening up about her future
including plans for marriage and kids i
find it fascinating with relationships
and people that are in love adele stuns
on the cover of elle magazine inside the
hello hit maker gushes about finding
romance with rich after divorce
quote i've never been in love like this
i'm obsessed with him
fans speculate that her single oh my god
was written with rich in mind
[Music]
well it's nice to hear an upbeat tune
from adele she's been going strong with
the super agent since making their
relationship instagram official back in
september
my lyrics have progressed but you know
they're always still about the same
thing me and um
seemingly my failed relationships which
is crazy excited don't feel like that
but yeah
adele first sparked romance rumors with
rich courtside at an nba finals game and
ever since they've been smitten with
each other and all loved up on dates
like in june when they attended a
friend's wedding in new york i feel very
lucky the big question is adele next to
tie the knot she sparked engagement
rumors when she was spotted rocking a
massive rock while performing at the
2022 brit awards but adele shut down any
speculation telling the mag i'm not
engaged i just love high-end jewelry
absolutely but marriage is still on the
table adele says she's down to say i do
again we're just waiting for rich to pop
the question quote i'm just in love i'm
happy as i'll ever be i might as well be
married
of course adele finding love with rich
comes after her marriage to simon kaneki
whom she split from in 2019. the ex's
shared nine-year-old son angelo
and now adele says she's ready to expand
her family with rich who has three kids
of his own i want a baby next year
adele says she and rich are renovating
their new home together with a blended
family in mind i definitely want more
kids i'm a homemaker and i'm a matriarch
and a stable life helps me with my music
[Music]
and while adele's got clear vision when
it comes to her personal life she's
still laser focused on her career
earlier this year the singer caught heat
for canceling her las vegas residency
last minute it's been impossible to
finish the show
and
i can't give you what i have right now
and i'm gutted i'm gutted and i'm sorry
it's the last minute she recalls being
embarrassed at the time but in
retrospect it actually made my
confidence in myself grow
adele's main focus now giving fans her
all at her rescheduled shows
i have plans next year
i to cancel shows cause i'm having a
baby
[Music]
you